ich habe hunderte von menschen dieses
den finanziell sehr schlecht geht
grundeinkommen ausgezahlt wird meinem
verein über die letzten jahre
ich habe mit der lupe danach gesucht
nach der einen person die alkohol kaufte
und faul wird und völlig verrottet das
gegenteil dass ihr seht doch auch keiner
von uns herzlich willkommen wir spielen
13 fragen hier kommt frage nummer 1
brauchen wir ein bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen ja oder nein
[Musik]
weniger existenzangst mehr freiheit das
ist die idee hinter dem bedingungslosen
grundeinkommen egal ob du arm bist oder
reich der staat zahlt jedem von uns
jeden monat 1200 euro aufs konto und
zwar ohne gegenleistung ohne bürokratie
stellt sich nur die frage wer soll das
bezahlen und geht dann überhaupt noch
jemand arbeiten was meint ihr würdet ihr
euch positionieren auf dem grünfeld oder
auf dem gelben schreibt mir gerne in die
kommentare so wo er steht wissen wir
natürlich schon das sehen wir auch ganz
gut in zukunft bitte folgende regel
beachten wenn er glaubt die gegenseite
machte einen guten punkt ein gutes
argument dann kommt gerne einen schritt
vor also einen schritt auf die
gegenseite zugelaufen wenn ihr aber
umgekehrt sagt ja das stimmt gar nicht
da bin ich vehement dagegen
dann geht ihr bitte einen schritt zurück
mein ziel ist es ganz klar kompromisse
zu finden und euch dazu zu bewegen eben
auch ins kompromiss fällt zusammen zu
kommen
ob das bei dem thema klappt schauen wir
mal
hier kommt frage zwei von 13 fragen und
die geht an unseren bäckermeister
carsten was würde ein bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen für deinen betrieb ich
glaube vierter generation inzwischen
bedeuten würdest du selbst aufhören zu
arbeiten also ich persönlich würde gar
nicht aufhören zu arbeiten also nicht
nur das backen ist mein leben sondern
auch das betrieb führen mache ich total
gerne um von daher sehe ich keine
notwendigkeit auch nicht wenn ich 1200
euro kriege da für mein beruf an nagel
zu hängen
weil ich mich persönlich darin erfüllt
sehen und welche auswirkung glaubst du
wird
das auf den betrieb auf personal etc
haben es gebe bestimmt schon einige
leute die sagen würden
dafür stehe ich nachts nicht auf oder
kommen würden und sagen ich möchte gerne
also ich verarbeite gerne bei dir weiter
aber zu denen und den bedingungen und
das ist für mich hätte größte
problematik weil ich nicht genau weiß
was dann auf mich zu kommen
beziehungsweise ob ich das nachher
leisten kann ich glaube dass die
befürworter des bedingungslosen
grundeinkommens einfach viele sachen
nicht bedenken die uns kleiner leute
oder uns kleine handwerker beschäftigen
und dass wir in vielen bereichen
vielleicht die sache nicht bis zu ende
durchdacht haben was verdient hat einen
bäcker azubi einbeck azubi im dritten
lehrjahr knapp 1 900 euro pro 900 euro
brutto
tonia wenn jetzt jemand kommt und dem
beckert sowie sagt pass auf du hast 1200
euro und muss nicht arbeiten oder du
kriegst 900 euro und kannst du schöne
ausbildung machen da hat er natürlich
sorge dass er dann keine auszubildenden
findet was eh schon schwierig ist was
würdest du ihm antworten also ich glaube
wenn der azubi 16 ist dann stimmt es
vielleicht manchmal aber auch nicht
immer ich glaube wenn der potenzielle
azubi vielleicht 28 oder 34 ist und sich
überlegt sie im beruf noch einmal neu zu
orientieren und sich überlegt sagt ich
möchte auch gern handwerk machen ich
kochte da garnicht bagdad gar nicht will
sehen was ich gemacht mit meinen händen
dann gewinnt man vielleicht sogar neue
lehrlinge die man folgern jungen schauen
hatte sei mit dem grundeinkommen
zusammen können dass nämlich dann
erwachsene menschen plötzlich doch das
ist richtig die azubis haben wir ja
schon aber das problem ist doch was
macht man mit der generation die von der
schule kommt bis sie wie du sagst
nachher weiß nicht 23 24 sind ich glaube
aber dass der generation bei den jungen
hast du auch nicht alle die irgendwie
sagen ich will nichts macht und ich will
nicht also ich glaube glauben dass wir
immer ein paar die sagen oh super ich
leg mich jetzt erstmal auf die faule
haut und du hast aber eine ganze menge
andere auch die sagen nein natürlich
will ich immer im leben mehr meint ein
grundeinkommen also aber die geldfrage
ist natürlich schon eine spannende frage
wie viel motivation dahinter steht
gerade wenn es an diesem grenzbereich
geht also um die 1000 1200 euro wenn das
ausbildungsgehalt so ähnlich oder
weniger sogar ist da muss man sich die
frage natürlich stellen interessiert
mich auch was ihr davon haltet was würde
mit dem geld machen euch auf die faule
haut legen oder sagen ich mach jetzt mal
was ganz anderes mal ist eine
bäckerlehre zb vielleicht gründet die
auch im business schreiben sie mir gerne
in die kommentare ich bin sehr gespannt
was eure meinung dazu ist wenn ihr auf
einmal 1200 euro bedingungslos auf dem
konto hätten wir noch mal ganz kurz bei
der frage was mit betrieben passiert die
gerade auch beschäftigte haben die auf
so einer ähnlichen gehaltsstufe wie zum
beispiel sind 200 euro sind ohne kannst
du dir sorgen nachvollziehen die manche
leute haben die sagen genau solche
betriebe kriegen dann ein problem
möglicherweise das kann ich tatsächlich
auf jeden fall nachvollziehen ich glaube
dass viele menschen insbesondere ruth
gut bezahlten oder hoch angesehenen
berufen dass sie ihre arbeit nicht
widerlegen werden aber ich kann mir
vorstellen dass leute die berufe machen
die ersten schlecht bezahlt sind und
zweitens schlecht angesehen sind das die
sich dann tatsächlich fragen warum soll
ich das eigentlich machen ich glaube
dass oft ein wunschdenken vorher ist und
das harte ökonomische fakten außen vor
gelassen werden und das halte ich
eigentlich für das größte problem daran
krank diese debatte meiner meinung nach
am meisten was genau meinst du damit
also beide jobs werden dann nicht mehr
erledigt zum beispiel bei
reinigungskräften könnte ich mir das gut
vorstellen das sind menschen die werden
ganz häufig schlecht behandelt haben
eine extrem harte arbeit zu leisten und
sie werden schlecht bezahlt und da muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen glaube ich dass
viele dieser menschen völlig zurecht
dann sagen nein möchte ich nicht das war
ihr seid beide gleich nach vorne
gegangen warum weil ich das das könnte
ein effekt von grundeinkommen sein es
kann sein dass also leute sind nicht
mehr erpressbar
sie haben zum ersten mal in der
geschichte die chancen eins zu sagen zur
arbeit die sie nicht für würdig erachten
und was würde passieren unternehmer
müssten mehr geld bezahlen
sie müssten die arbeit selber machen sie
müssten die arbeit auf mehrere schultern
verlagern oder die arbeitsbedingungen
verbessern meinen grundeinkommen will
nicht groß palavern sondern einfach
machen und deshalb sammeln wir geld das
dann an menschen verschenkt wird als
grundeinkommen für ein jahr das haben
wir bereits über 700 mal gemacht und
damit sammeln wir zum ersten mal reale
praxiserfahrung wieder danke
grundeinkommen wirklich ein leben
verändern
jetzt stellen wir uns einmal vor ich
habe mich wenn man kein netter
arbeitgeber und sage mir 1200 euro das
also mehr gibt's nicht ja und dann sagt
die putzkraft zum beispiel weil wir da
bei dem thema wann ich bleibe zu hause
jetzt sagt der arbeitgeber aber ich hole
mir die leute von draußen rein die für
1200 euro arbeiten
die kriegen das denn auch das ist eine
frage welches modell man im fast alle
grundeinkommens modelle außer die von
ganz rechts außen die sagen dass den
menschen grundeinkommen ausgezahlt
werden soll
die auch in deutschland gemeldet sind
wenn sie hier zum beispiel arbeiten also
ja diesen mist laufen
nein also ich glaube das modell so wie
es jetzt klingt ist ja jeder kriegt 1200
euro sodann sagt michael und jeder der
arbeitet kriegt sofort noch mehr ich bin
gegen das bedingungslose grundeinkommen
weil ich glaube dass man es überhaupt
gar nicht finanzieren kann und dass die
leute die ein bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen wollen an einem traum
schloss bauen dann wird es doch du als
böser arbeitgeber sagen super ich
brauche jetzt jemanden der hier reinigt
den hätte ich normalerweise sagen wir
mal 1400 brutto gezahlt jetzt kriegt ja
er war ja schon 1200 netto 1
grundeinkommen das nehme ich als
subvention meines betriebes denn ich
mache das jetzt so die putzfrau die
kriegt jetzt nur noch 600 brutto macht
ja nichts weil sie hat ja noch das
grundeinkommen und hat mehr als vorher
mag was sagst du zu dem argument dass
möglicherweise arbeitgeber das ganze
einfach missbrauchen und den leuten
dumpinglöhne zahlen um das zu verhindern
jetzt wirklich zu verhindern dass ein
arbeitgeber plötzlich sagt so ich setzte
mich unter druck
ich zahle jetzt plötzlich noch drei euro
die stunde dann haben wir die
möglichkeit mit politischen willen zu
sagen dass das akzeptieren wir
grundsätzlich nicht es gibt ja heute
schon mindestlohn und das wird sicher
das wird sicher auch mit einer
bedingungslosen grundeinkommen nicht
ändern müssen
ich glaube wir brauchen
vielmehr modellversuche zum
grundeinkommen die staatlich finanziert
sind und die vor allem auch von den
menschen ausgehen weil ich glaube dass
wir menschen auf diesem weg deutlich
freier solidarischer und produktiver
werden missbrauch vermeiden durch
mindestlohn ist doch auch ein argument
ulrike genau dann stelle ich mich mal
hier vorne hin das ist richtig also ich
bin absolut glücklich bin absolut für
mindestlöhne nur ein punkt wäre eben
dass man wenn man jetzt sozusagen das
los der niedrigverdiener verbessern will
man nicht diesen weiten umweg um das
bedingungslose grundeinkommen gehen
sollte das aus meiner sicht nie kommt
sondern dass man dann stattdessen sofort
als reform fraktion sagen sollte
wir wollen höheren mindestlohn also
beispielsweise mindestlohn von 15 euro
ohne du sagst ja grundeinkommen ist auch
deswegen schon mal grundsätzlich eine
falsche idee weil es einfach ungerecht
ist wie man zu dass ja ich würde sagen
dass nicht jeder den gleichen bedarf hat
also für mich können 1200 euro jetzt
prima ausreichen
beispielsweise habe ich aber jahrelang
wochenenden jungen mit geistiger
behinderung betreut der brauch mehr geld
beziehungsweise dessen mutter braucht
mehr geld weil er insbesondere eine sehr
intensive betreuung brauchen sonst ist
das für die gar nicht zu stemmen
was ich mich dann frage ist ein
grundeinkommen das diesen namen verdient
müsste für ihn also höher seien
unterschiedlich hoch und dann wäre es
aber nicht mehr bedingungslos sondern
seinen grundeinkommen das höher wäre als
meines wäre an die bedingung geknüpft er
hat eine behinderung deshalb hat er
recht auf mehr geld gibt es dann
überhaupt sowas wie ein bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen für alle also diese 1200
euro für alle muss ich ganz klar sagen
die überzeugen ich gar nicht könnt ihr
das nachvollziehen dass ohne sagt na ja
das funktioniert aber so nicht und das
ist irgendwie an sich ungerecht wenn
alle das gleiche kriegen ich kann den
gedanken nachvollziehen und das beispiel
nachvollziehen was du gebracht hast das
ja gesagt was passiert dann mit menschen
besondere bedarfe haben
bei denen ist das dann nicht abgedeckt
aber da will ich auch noch mal sagen
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen bedeutet
ja nicht dass ich sage sozialsystem wird
abgeschafft und ganz grundsätzlich
glaube ich grundeinkommen wenn wir es
uns als menschenrecht vorstellen das
finde ich spannend dass man sagt du bist
auf der welt und allein dafür sage ich
deine existenz
es ist abgesichert das finde ich
grundsätzlich gut zu sagen wir brauchen
grundlegende menschenrecht also da
könnte ich jetzt schon wieder ein tor
machen aber fast schon wieder zurück ich
mich nämlich frage warum ein
grundlegendes menschenrecht auf einen
nominalen geldbetrag warum sagt man
nicht jeder so ein dach über dem kopf
haben bildung zugang zu kultur und so
weiter und so fort warum ein nominaler
geld also schreibe stimmen muss dann
hast so das ist das ist das menschenbild
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts wo eine
zentraleinheit wie zum beispiel der
staat weiß was ein gutes leben bedeutet
und wir merken das passt nicht mehr auf
die vielfältigen lebensentwürfe gibt
doch den leuten das geld und die können
selbst entscheiden vielleicht will einem
wald leben und hat gar keine mietkosten
du kommst der auch an der
verwaltungsgrenze du musst das ja alles
organisieren wenn du sagst wie man leben
soll und dann den leuten irgendwelche
güter zustands und wir merken das
funktioniert nicht ganz kurz zur
gerechtigkeit frage ich mich natürlich
eure meinung ist das bedingungslose
grundeinkommen im kern ungerecht so wie
es ohne gesagt hat oder ist es im
gegenteil sogar genau recht vielleicht
sogar menschenrecht wie es mag gerade
gesagt hat schreibt gerne in die
kommentare und wir gehen jetzt so ein
bisschen von der gerechtigkeitsfrage hin
zur sicherheitsfrage zu tun ja du hast
ja mit dem bedingungslosen
grundeinkommen eigentlich überhaupt gar
nichts am hut gehabt aber was ist dann
passieren er nicht ganz gar nichts als
war sympathisant und fand die idee immer
spannend aber ja dann kam die krise und
die große pressekonferenz mit der bei
super am 13 märz letztes jahr
ich habe auf change am anfang der krise
eine petition gestartet für ein krisen
grundeinkommen ein bedingungsloses weil
mir ganz schnell klar dass wir die sehr
viele menschen in eine sehr ungewissen
situation rutschen würden und viele
viele viele leute einfriert sicherheit
bräuchten ja ich weiß es gibt diese
sicherheitsnetze aber es ist ein krasser
bürokratieaufwand und ich weiß gerade
bei der grundsicherung ganz ganz ganz
ganz ganz ich glaube 5 prozent der
selbstständigen die eigentlich gerade
anspruch hatten beantragen sie weil die
anderen alle angst haben vor
repressalien wenn ich dann irgendwo
erstmal steht knie vielleicht später
keine unternehmer kredite mehr
was auch immer schamgrenze sagen hey ich
habe 19 jahre lang arbeitsplätze
geschafft oder für mich selbst gesagt
also viele sind auch so dass ich einfach
sagen ich habe mich immer selber an den
haaren aus dem sumpf gezogen und das
schaffe ich jetzt irgendwie auch da
verkaufen lieber vorher meine möbel und
das heißt du
die ist für einen krisen grundeinkommen
oder für ein immer geld also in diesem
fall und eben die petition die ich auch
gestartet habe damals ging es um einen
krisen grundeinkommen während der korona
krise allerdings hatte ich natürlich ein
bisschen im jahr so viel kontakt mit dem
thema grundeinkommen dass ich inzwischen
schon auch ganz klar einfach die
vorteile sehen dieses für unsere
gesellschaft hat mit dem grundeinkommen
kannst du dann halt doch mal irgendwann
auch an der stelle sagen okay oder wir
haben gerade eine flaute aber ich weiß
zumindest meine miete und meine
krankenkasse sinke zeit weniger charme
weniger bürokratie mehr sicherheit
ulrike überzeugt ich dass ich glaube
eben nicht dass es möglich wäre jetzt
mitten in der krise ein bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen für alle zu hierzu
stellen denn das würde beispielsweise
bedeuten dass leute die eine stelle
haben also im extremfall beamte oder
auch leute die deren jobs ganz normal
weiter laufen zum beispiel in der
bäckerei die sind ja auch im vollbetrieb
oder in lebensmittelläden oder in online
händlern oder in die industrie der geben
da geht es ja schon wieder aufwärtsgehen
alle jobs die würden dann auch eine das
bedingungslose grundeinkommen bekommen
und da würde ich dann einfach sagen da
reicht das geld nie was ist denn die
vision dahinter warum wird gesellschaft
dadurch besser wir müssen glaube ich mal
eine sache klären wenn es um die
finanzierung geht ich hoffe dass ich
sagen kann dass man mich versteht das
grundeinkommen hat ein großes mysterium
um sich und das ist die idee es habe ich
euch bei euch gehört ist dass alle
menschen 1200 euro mehr haben so ein
grundeinkommen kann und wird es niemals
geben das wäre gedruckt das geld wenn es
vom himmel fällt inflation sofort weg
gibt es nicht grundeinkommen danken es
wird umverteilt sie kriegen 1200 euro im
monat mehr
das ist erstmal schön aber es nur der
monatsanfang am ende zahlen sie deutlich
höhere steuern als heute das heißt in
der mittelschicht zahlen sie
wahrscheinlich mittel auch ungefähr 1200
euro pro monat steuern mehr
das heißt unter dem strich haben sie
nicht mehr geld in der tasche das schöne
ist dass es auch nicht schlimm
die haben aber eine sicherheit sie
wissen dass sie und ihre kinder bis zum
lebensende niemals in armut leben werden
und die hoffnung ist dass menschen dann
klügere entscheidungen fällen weil sie
nicht mehr so tief fallen können je nach
maß der umverteilung je nach partei
konzept ist das grundeinkommen höher
oder niedriger und es bedeutet dann dass
die armen etwas mehr und
die reichen wenige haben es ist eine
große steuerreform aber keine
steuerreform wo der staat mehr geld
wegnimmt und damit autobahnen wird es in
berlin zu bauen sondern eine
umlageverfahren zwischen den menschen
das heißt es ist nicht mehr geld
deswegen gibt es keinen inflation und
deswegen ist es auch nicht schwer zu
finanzieren denn die meisten menschen
haben heute bereits 1200 euro unter
deutlich mehr und grundeinkommen wächst
quasi von unten in das existierende
einkommen hinein
aber das würde doch dann so laufen dann
hätte ich als vierköpfige familie schon
mal 56.000 euro netto netto wenn ich gar
nicht arbeit so dann denke ich mir
vielleicht okay jetzt will ich aber doch
ein bisschen arbeiten macht ja spaß
dann ist auch die wahrscheinlichkeit
groß dass ich sage okay ich mache aber
nur eine halbtagsstelle dann habe ich
wahnsinnige steuern aber insgesamt habe
ich trotzdem viel mehr als vorher und
meine steuern reichen nicht um mich
selbst zu finanzieren
bei den tbr quatsch genauso viel zu
arbeiten wie vorher wenn ich eigentlich
auch und bedingungsloses grundeinkommen
machen kann und stattdessen verfolge ich
dann meine hobbys das ist auch zutiefst
menschlich und das will ich auch gar
nicht kritisieren aber dann mache ich
zum beispiel den kirchenchor so oder
irgendwas abriss so und dann ist aber
jetzt die frage ganz banal warum sollen
die die noch arbeiten und steuern zahlen
jetzt und die nicht gläubig sind das
hobby von jemandem finanzieren da jetzt
den kirchenchor leitet da gehe ich nach
vorne weil ich stimme dir 100 prozent zu
wenn es so ist dass ein grundeinkommen
die menschen fall macht dann ist es
nicht möglichst nicht finanzierbar wir
müssen ja geld umverteilen und dafür
müssen menschen erwerbs arbeiten die
frage ist nur arbeiten menschen nur
deshalb weil es einen vorteil gibt weil
es weil sie dann geld haben oder
arbeiten sie weil es sinn stiftet weil
es weil sie weil es das leben sinnvoll
macht ich glaube menschen wollen
arbeiten und werden es auch und viel
besser mit grundeinkommen tun
das erleben wir auch bei den 700
menschen den wir grundeinkommen
ausgezahlt haben die bilden sich weiter
die finden jobs die sogar besser bezahlt
werden da kommt keiner
selbst leute mit vier prekären jobs
gleichzeitig kommt keiner auf die idee
weniger zu tun und wir müssen das
herausfinden aber das ist doch jetzt ein
großer glaubensfrage und
lasst uns doch mal mit der gaskrise
ulrike ist gerade mehrere schritte nach
hinten gelaufen aber nicht gerade dachte
ihr werdet euch einig geworden aber
jetzt bist du trotzdem nach hinten der
ansatz von michaelis ja wir erlauben den
menschen nicht zu arbeiten
aber das kommt nicht so weil die
arbeiten an der trotzdem aber das ist
quatsch weil alle systeme die wir haben
alle sozialsysteme rechtssysteme und so
weiter sind so ausgelegt dass alle sie
in anspruch nehmen können das ist der
witz so ist jedes sozialsystem
krankenkasse unfallversicherung alles
ist genau so strukturiert wer berechtigt
ist darf es an anspruch nehmen nur das
grundeinkommen wäre ein system wo so
laufen würde man hat ein recht man darf
das aber nicht in anspruch nehmen wenn
das wenn ich in aller eile in anspruch
nehmen würden würde zusammenbrechen
sowas gibt es aber auf der welt nicht
wenn es einen rechtsruck gibt nun
möglich sein dass alle es in anspruch
nehmen es geht ja gar nicht darum das
sozialbudget umzuverteilen
sondern es geht eigentlich ihres
volkseinkommen also das
bruttoinlandsprodukt wird muss
umverteilt werden darum geht es und das
wird das wird natürlich wird das wird
das wird passieren müssen das wird wird
witzig bringen was aber nicht bedeutet
dass es das ist also diese frage ist es
nicht finanzierbar oder ist es
finanzierbar
ja auf jeden fall es ist erwiesen in
vielen studien dass die höhe von
transferleistung dass die auszahlung
sogar von einem bedingungslosen
grundeinkommen über viele jahre über
tausende von menschen keinen relevanten
effekt hat auf die frage ob ich arbeiten
gehe oder nicht der mensch ist ein
soziales wesen er möchte tätig sein
menschen haben depressionen weil sie
keine arbeit haben sie wollen etwas
beitragen kassen habt ihr seid ihr da
drüben bisschen zu verbissen in details
und umsetzbarkeit und seht nicht das
große ganze die vision die er gerade
gezeichnet hat den kasten also lasst
mich gefragt willst du hast oder
angeguckt
ich hab' ich habe also geld geschaut
also und also ich habe gerade den
eindruck dass du mehr oder weniger
moniert dass hier nicht einmal wie man
quasi auf der fahrt träumt auch weil
noch eine andere welt also es geht doch
so nicht weiter wie heute habe ich habe
sich einsam das zu anfang an gesagt also
ich bin ja gerne dabei dass man zu
träumen
aber ich kann ja nichts gegen meine
ängste oder gegen meine bedenken machen
nur weil du dich hinstellt und sagt das
wird schon
das stimmt nicht ich es auf fakten
basiert was ich erzähle ich glaube wir
müssen wir müssen noch mehr forschung
schaffen es gibt aber auch eine menge
und wir müssen nicht so tun als würden
die menschen sofort auf wenn zu arbeiten
es ist nicht zu belegen sagt ja
überhaupt nicht nur dann also du
bestimmst du doch grundsätzlich zu dass
wenn die menschen aufhören würden zu
aber nicht herzlich alle hören auf zu
arbeiten sondern auch nur zehn prozent
20 prozent der arbeit und nicht mehr
getan
dann steht dem nominalen
bruttoinlandsprodukt ein real gesenkt
des bip stand entgegen das bedeutet also
die menschen haben real weniger das ist
okay wir können gerne meinetwegen sagen
wir arbeiten weniger haben dafür weniger
machen schöne sachen machen den
kirchenchor finde ich prima muss man
aber so kommunizieren und das wird nicht
getan stattdessen wird gesagt heute
reichen 1200 euro aus um sich ein prima
leben leisten zu können dass der brauch
mit 1200 euro grundeinkommen obwohl wir
wissen dass wir zusammen gekommen eben
dass diese 1200 euro vielleicht nicht
mehr reichen nach einführung des
grundeinkommens und dann kommen wir
einfach nur eine grundeinkommens
inflationsspirale das stimmt ich gehe
jetzt ganz nach vorne
also sollte man nur bei der gegenseite
nachfolger läuft auch hin wo du weißt du
das geld ja heute schon was wissen wir
über die zukunft der also dass irgendwer
von uns sechs was würde es für uns eine
sehr persönliche ändern wenn wir jetzt
grundeinkommen trainer wie schon gesagt
war für mich gar nichts das ist gut für
dich und du dich auch nicht aber jeder
der mit dem man im gespräch darauf
kommen fast jeder sagt also ich würde
nichts ändern ich werde genauso weiter
arbeiten gehen man kann das daran liegen
dass man immer auch mit verhältnis also
ich weiß wir für euch ist aber ein
verhältnis mit sie profitierten leuten
auch redet ich bin podcaster ich mein
buch autor ja was ich mache macht mir
spaß ich bin erfüllt das bringt auch ein
anderer sozialer anerkennung trifft
nicht für alle zu was ist mit denen auf
die gäste aus meiner sicht ein
versteckter chauvinismus dahinter der
nämlich sagt fowler alarme menschen sind
ein bisschen dumm und faul deswegen
sondern kommen ausgezahlt mit meinem
verein in den letzten jahre
ich habe mit der lupe danach gesucht
nach der einen person die alkohol kaufte
und faul wird und völlig verloren das
gegenteil ist passiert jedoch auch
keiner
die sozialversicherungspflichtige
beschäftigung geht zurück und
stattdessen machen die leute kirchenchor
wenn die sie nicht faul
der punkt ist nur sie machen nicht die
arbeit jedenfalls nicht in dem ausmaß
wie bisher auf dem das steuersystem
basiert das ist unsere behauptet dass
und das wird auch das springen sind die
journalisten sind unsere aber was heißt
schon was mag wieder reinholen und max
marck meldet sich schon die ganze zeit
tschuldigung bevor wort verbeißen ich
glaube dass wir es einfach noch nicht
wissen ich glaube das ist das ist
wahrscheinlich nie wissen werden wir es
nicht ausprobieren
ich glaube das ist ich habe immer
gleichzeitig auch den punkt dass ich
sage nicht nur geld hat ein wert für
unsere gesellschaft sondern es gibt so
viele aspekte von zusammenleben sagt es
gibt so viele aspekte auch von arbeit
von betätigung die wichtigsten für
unsere gesellschaft die ich aus über die
ich jetzt nicht außer acht lassen würde
und gleichzeitig denke ich trotzdem dass
es vielleicht sogar sein könnte dass wir
danach mehr erwerbsarbeit haben mehr
erwerbstätigkeit haben als heute
das wissen wir nicht ich glaube dass der
der distanz der hier manchmal im raum
steht dass er gar nicht so groß da ist
das hat natürlich das auch mit dem
sozialismus ganz im zeichen von mir
weisen weil ich auch nicht möchte dass
leute schlecht bezahlte jobs machen
müssen
ich möchte auch nicht dass menschen
durch hat viele sanktionen daran gezeigt
werden da bin ich komplett eurer meinung
nur ich halte das grundeinkommen
weiterhin trotzdem für den fall zu weg
muss schneider sein das ist doch in
dieser stelle mal eine runde der
kompromisse machen zum ende
ihr wisst ja mir geht es zumindest darum
auch bei klarem die sense irgendwie zu
gucken wo gibt es einen konsens nun wir
versuchen also dass man raus zu finden
ihr seid gleich selbst innerhalb eurer
gruppen aufgefordert kompromissvorschlag
zu machen wo er sagt vielleicht gehen
die anderen da einen schritt auf mich zu
ich biete selber auch einen vorschlag an
ich glaube den auch schon nur mehr oder
weniger raus gehört zu haben also der
vorschlag lautet wenigstens die menschen
die heute hartz4 empfangen sollten in
ein bedingungsloses grundeinkommen
überführt werden unbürokratisch ohne
stigmata unbedingt das gleiche einkommen
also es wäre also für diejenigen wäre es
innerhalb dieser kaste wäre es quasi ein
bedingungsloses aber quasi ein bedingtes
grundeinkommen für die menschen die
heutzutage hat vier empfangen wäre das
ein kompromissvorschlag wo er sagt da
gehe ich einen schritt vor oder nicht
also ich bin ambitioniert
also also es gibt eine leichte bewegung
die richtung aber übrig bleibt noch
stehen ja aber es zum beispiel wenn man
finde ich es schon richtig dass
weiterhin versucht wird leute in arbeit
zu vermitteln also das prinzip des
forderns und förderns würde dann
aufgehoben werden also ich glaube nicht
dass ich das unterstützen
jetzt würde ich euch bitten geht kurz in
euch am besten ihr könnt euch gerne
zusammen stellen merkt euch ungefähr
eure position bisschen macht es ganz
kurz jetzt nicht ewig lang denken und
rum formulieren gibt es irgendwo ihr
sagt damit kriegen wir die anderen
wissen er zu uns
während meine gäste noch am diskutieren
sind wenn ihr auch vielleicht einen
vorschlag hat
wie können hier beide seiten näher
zusammenkommen dann schreibt es mir
gerne in die kommentare ich bin sehr
gespannt
er ist ja ein wichtiges thema das uns
alle angeht und offenbar gibt es ja auch
den bedarf nach kompromissen bin
gespannt so damen und herren wir kommen
langsam zum schluss bitte ihr dürft
euren ersten vorschlag machen
ja wir hatten hier so eine art
gruppensprecher naja ich habe den
eindruck dass wir auch innerhalb der
gruppen klein das seltsam weil ulrike
gegen die aufhebung der sanktionen ist
ich würde gerne harte sanktionen
aufheben von daher würden wir vielleicht
moderatorin vorschlag machen wo wir alle
hinter stehen das wäre erhöhung von
hartz 4
dass das nicht mehr künstlich klein
gerechnet wird so wie es jetzt gerade
stattfindet insbesondere die
erniedrigenden praktiken von jobcentern
was unterricht gemeinte da wird noch im
badezimmer geguckt wie viele zahnbürsten
da sind so bisschen übertrieben
gesprochen all das muss aufhören würden
wir sagen genau also hartz 4 radikal
verbessern aber die sanktionen nicht
gänzlich abschaffen sanktionen klingt ja
so drakonisch ich meine es muss schon so
sein dass die leute tatsächlich
arbeitslose nicht und das muss auch
kontrolliert werden also nicht in dem
sinne dass jeder der sagt ich will hartz
iv zum jobcenter gehen kann die
bedingung wäre ein bedarf ja genau
aber darf kann den ich auch sagen ich
bin alleinerziehend und nur 30 stunden
und braucht ja das würde ich finde ich
völlig okay genau weiß noch nicht hat
hier im moment aber trotzdem jahr mit
einem minimum
deswegen finde ich die begrenzung auf
hartz4 da bisschen schwierig ja man kann
natürlich sagen grundsicherung wird also
siegerin zu anderen entzünden die gdl
hat es viel müsste weiter oben sein das
ist ja das was wir vorschlagen also hat
sich der aufenthalt und wer entscheidet
ob sie der depp der rote punkt weswegen
derjenige dem bedarf hat angemessen ist
oder nicht also zum beispiel sein
ich will noch eine umschulung machen in
einem bestimmten alter will noch mal
eine ausbildung machen oder aus meiner
sicht ist es so dass das dann
tatsächlich trotzdem das jobcenter
entscheiden muss weil ich glaube
also anders als ihr ne ganz pragmatisch
gesprochen es gibt nicht die
gesellschaftliche bereitschaft leute
bedingungslos zu finanzieren
also es muss die gesellschaft ist nur
bereit dieses geld aufzubringen
also in form einer bedingten
grundsicherung die sehr viel besser
ausgestattet ist wenn sie das gefühl
haben
okay da wird auch geguckt wer kriegt das
denn jetzt und warum das könnte ja sein
dass ich das auch änderte die
gesellschaftliche bereitschaft könnte ja
nach den 200 pilotprojekten auch ganz
woanders wäre es theoretisch ich rede
jetzt von der gegend von dagegen nicht
von der zukunft finden ok habt ihr euch
irgendwie bewegt ihr seid so ja würde
mal versuchen führen zu sprechen dass
wir uns sehr wünschen dass die aktuelle
soziale sicherung verbessert wird dass
menschen aus der akuten armut geholt
werden weil das ist ein riesenproblem
corona verschärftes und macht es noch
sichtbar
das ist ein absolut notwendiger schritt
zu dem wir glaube ich alle stehen ihr
könnt also auch dazu
trotzdem müssen wir leider sagen dass
sie beim thema bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen nicht bereits sind
abstriche zu machen ist eine radikal
einfache idee eine idee die nicht
versucht ein kaputtes system irgendwie
bug zu fixen und ein bisschen halbwegs
armut zu verdecken indem man
nachträglich in not geratene menschen
die es immer wieder geben wird in diesem
system irgendwie über die runden zu
bringen sondern wir wollen ein system in
dem von vornherein niemand in die not
gerät in denen menschen nicht misstraut
wird in denen sie nicht kontrolliert
werden von einem staat der sagt wenn man
leistung trägt oder nicht sondern wir
wollen eine welt in der menschen
vertraut wird weil wir glauben dass sie
dann über sich hinauswachsen und eine
neue welt schaffen deshalb für euch
heute leider kein kompromiss angebot
darf ich noch einen letzten machen ich
wollte ein fragesteller hasna ich habe
noch eine fixe idee was ist denn wenn
man das grundeinkommen nicht gleich von
beginn der geburt macht sondern mit zum
späteren zeitpunkt gibt es konzept jetzt
also dass man sagen reisten als die
konzepte gibt an dass du sagst du fängst
mit 30 40 an also sagt man ja ich bin
jetzt mitte 40
angenommen ich könnte mich nicht selbst
verwirklichen hätte jetzt aber bock
nochmal eine sprache zu lernen oder weiß
ich von mir nur zu reisen oder nochmal
ein neues business aufzuziehen oder
sowas
also das wäre für mich so eine sache
dann hast du wenigstens meine
befürchtung war ja auch dass die
schulabgänger studienabgängern erstmal
ins arbeitsleben also ihnen das
arbeitsleben gezeigt werden muss oder
sie integriert werden müssen
aber wir haben eine perspektive dass sie
irgendwann auch mal was anderes machen
können warum nicht dagegen ist das
charmante an dieser idee ist dass das
aufhört menschen in gruppen zu
unterteilen stammschloss du immer jemand
der zu entscheidet welche lobby gruppe
setzt sich quasi durch dann haben zum
beispiel die kinder und die erwerbslosen
und die armen und die ausländer haben
dann alle keine lobby gruppe und kriegen
dann komischerweise wieder nichts ein
grundeinkommen sagt schluss mit dem
quatsch alle kriegen genug punkt so ich
mache noch einen allerletzten
kompromissvorschlag nur das wird diesmal
auf dem tisch liegt ein bedingungsloses
nicht einkommen sondern eine
bedingungslose finanzspritze nenne ich
mal zb zum achtzehnten lebensjahr
bekommt jeder vom staat 30.000 euro
überwiesen das ist kein einiges
günstiger als ein bg 30.000 euro du
kannst damit machen was du willst kannst
du im haus investieren kannst reisen
gehen kannst keine ahnung was machst du
springst gleich nach vorn und manche
gehen gleich nach hinten was sagt ihr
nur ganz kurz kurze einschätzung keine
langen reden warum bist du nach vorne
gegangen weil ich glaube dass man
wirkliche sicherheitsgefühl vor allem
durch vermögen und nicht so sehr durch
einkommen kriegt und ich glaube dass es
für ganz viel mehr chancengleichheit
sorgen würde ich sagen würde das ist
ungerecht ist das ist jetzt wirklich mal
gießkannen prinzip jeder kriegt gleich
viel zum achtzehnten geburtstag und das
halte ich persönlich einfach für
ungerecht das stimmt dagegen ziemlich
schritt zurück weil das natürlich auch
einen punkt ja gut jetzt sind aber alle
vorschläge mal auf dem tisch gewesen
darum geht es ja auch ernsthaft
miteinander probiert er wir sind es halt
nicht einig geworden aber ich glaube
wenn ich das so interpretieren darf
ruhig gewünscht sich im alten mehr und
ich wünsche mir komplett was neues und
da kommt man schon von jeher nicht so
gut zusammen aber deswegen macht es umso
mehr spaß ich da immer wieder dran
auszutauschen ich glaube was wichtig ist
wir sind uns einig im ziel
also wir wollen ja beide dass kein
mensch in armut lebt wir wollen beide
dass die menschen glücklich sind wir
wollen dass kein druck ausgeübt wird
aber ich glaube der unterschied ist in
weg also ich nehme für mich mit dass ich
eure seite vielleicht besser verstehen
bei fragen sind geblieben klar bei mir
bleiben auch fragen also ich muss ja
schon zugeben mit den großen wirtschaft
sein
das überlasse ich auch immer gerne
anderen anderes mit genau den ganzen
anderen grundeinkommen profis und ich
glaube halt einfach trotz allem man muss
das einfach ausprobieren
ich fand diese diskussion super spannend
ich hatte auch das gefühl dass wir in
vielen punkten uns irgendwie ganz gut
ergänzen und auch nicht so weit
auseinander sind weiß nicht was du
siehst ohne das sehe ich eigentlich ganz
genau so ich möchte auch nicht dass wir
schlecht bezahlte jobs annehmen ich
möchte auch dass sie dann dach über dem
kopf hat und abgesichert ist aber das
instrument hat es leider weiterhin für
falsch
vielleicht gibt es ja so denn vielleicht
peter hebel ja irgendwann auf die andere
seite habe ich immer noch hoffnung dass
das jetzt auch im nachhinein heute
unsere heutigen diskussion hat sich
gezeigt da gibt es schon
da gibt's schon potenzial das wir uns da
immer weiter annähern natürlich ist am
ende des tages spannend also hier war
viel bewegung auf dem spielfeld vielen
dank dafür
finde ich super dass ihr auch
aufeinander zugeht und manchmal dann
auch wieder ein schritt zurückgeht wie
geht's euch wo steht ihr seid ihr mehr
team gelb oder team grün für
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen oder
dagegen oder vielleicht für einen dieser
kompromissvorschläge ich habe das gefühl
die mindestens reform von hartz 4 steht
auf jeden fall ganz oben auf allen
prioritätenlisten zumindest als erster
schritt vielen vielen dank fürs
mitmachen 13 fragen wann das danke er
natürlich hat weder team grün team gelb
restlos überzeugt oder umgekehrt aber
was sich so spannend fand an dieser
diskussion dass ich so was raus gespielt
hat dann doch so eine gemeinsamkeit so
ein konsens darüber dass man
sozialsysteme in deutschland ganz
offenbar besser aufstellen muss und das
ist ja schon mal was
welche argumente haben euch überzeugt
schreibt gerne in die kommentare und
wenn ihr mehr lust auf 13 fragen habt
hier könnt ihr unseren kanal abonnieren
hier oben findet ihr ein weiteres video
von 13 fragen und hier gibt es auch ein
video zum thema